i think we just want our child to pursue
whatever would make them happy you know
and if that's what they believe
would make them happy then then
absolutely
well fast forward to 2022 and charlie
sheen might have changed his tune after
daughter sammy reveals she's joined only
fans if they get older
there's not much we can do sammy who
turned 18 in march shared her only fan's
announcement on instagram posing in a
bikini at a pool the caption in the pic
click the link in my bio if you want to
see more so how are her famous parents
reacting whatever they want to do i just
want them happy and follow their passion
and their heart mom denise richards is
true to her work showing some love in
the comments quote sammy i will always
support you and always have your back i
love you but dad yeah he's not on the
same page in a statement to et charlie
seemingly blames denise for sammy's
career move
she is 18 years old now and living with
her mother this did not occur under my
roof while only fans is a platform for
all content creators it's gained a
reputation as the go-to social media for
adult entertainers which seems to be
charlie's issue his statement continues
quote i do not condone this but since
i'm unable to prevent it i urged her to
keep it classy creative and not
sacrifice her integrity now denise fired
back with a response of her own telling
e.t quote sammy is 18 and this decision
wasn't based on whose house she lives in
all i can do as a parent is guide her
and trust her judgment but she makes her
own choices i don't ever want to push my
kids to do something they don't want to
do but i encourage them if that is
something they want to do than to try it
and explore different things that they
may not have tried before and i always
think it's good for kids to have a
passion charlie denise's co-parenting
struggles have played out in the press
since they split in 2005. it was all
about
as i said
achieving
an unpolluted relationship with my
children and that is all that matters
they also share daughter lola who is now
16 the couple broke up while denise was
still pregnant with lola they finalized
their divorce a year later in 2006
and the following years were marked with
ups and downs with charlie's public
battles with substance abuse and the law
taking over the tabloids
yeah i am on a drug it's called charlie
sheen um
it uh it's not available because if you
try it once you will die your face will
melt off and your children will weep
over your exploded body
too much denise got full custody of the
girls in 2010 but it wasn't smooth
sailing from there in 2021 sammy showed
a sense-deleted tick-tock holding back
tears and claiming she was living in an
abusive household with her mom at the
time she moved in with her dad but has
since returned to living under denise's
roof and all seems well with the two now
who spent mother's day together and as
we've seen denise continues to stand by
her daughter as she takes the next steps
into adulthood i love someone that much
it's just it's unbelievable